well the president gave Republicans a
master class in retaliating against the
tactics of the left today undoubtedly
weary of watching the daily smear storm
buffeting his Supreme Court nominee
Brett Kavanaugh president Trump decided
it was time to do what he does best
fight back
the Democrats are playing a college
co-ed a time game is there any shame
they know he's high quality and they
wink at each other
they're winking they know at the time
yeah well Donald Trump is never gonna be
content to hang back and play defense
when he sees his agenda in jeopardy well
he tried that a little bit for a few
days last week when the Ford allegation
was dropped and he won praise for being
measured and presidential that's nice
but meanwhile his nominee was under
massive left-wing assault as Republicans
on the committee were bending over
backwards to accommodate the accusers
demands for delays in various conditions
well Trump is back and not a moment too
soon
it's a shame that you can do this to a
person's life and I'll tell you maybe
even more importantly who's gonna want
to go before this system to be a Supreme
Court judge for it to be a judge for it
to be even a politician that's a great
point and you notice how he boils it all
down to a stark set of facts facts that
can be understood by all Americans and
he's unafraid when everyone else is
telling him don't do it don't do it when
necessary to counterpunch 36 years ago
nobody ever do it better nobody ever
heard about it and now a new charge
comes up and she said well it might not
be him she thinks make it put in him
maybe not she admits that she was drunk
she admits time lapses time lapses well
and he's taking the same approach on the
world stage at the UN today as the
global elites shifted in their chairs
uncomfortably he delivered a fiercely
pro-american pro sovereignty message we
will never surrender America sovereignty
to an unelected unaccountable global
bureaucracy America is governed by
Americans we reject the ideology of
globalism and we embrace the doctrine of
patriotism well he is defiant he's
unapologetic clear we need more not less
of that today but I want to get back to
Kavanagh because last week with Trump on
the sidelines Senate Republicans walked
right into the trap set by the left-wing
smear squad so folks like senator flake
Collins and Murkowski they felt
pressured to give in to the me2
militants forcing Senate Judiciary
Committee Chair Chuck Grassley to
postpone last Thursday's Kavanagh vote
when the Democrats though were given an
inch they took a mile and they began to
slowly take the confirmation process
hostage and what did Republicans get for
all their cooperation and sensitivity an
extended vicious news cycle
I've heard you know many many predators
say and and refute allegations against
but she has nothing to gain here and
everything to lose that he was a drunken
almost rapist and think about that
they're willing to put on the Supreme
Court someone who very well may be a
essentially a sexual predator well a mob
like circus and the hallways of the
Senate offices and now anti Cavanaugh
nasties are targeting and trying to
humiliate Republican senators when
they're out in public
well I think most Americans bristle at
this stuff
these uncivil tactics and slimy smears
against good people I think are exposing
just how radicalized how contemptible
some strains of today's Democratic Party
has become but I think there is
something positive that's emerged in all
of this
Republicans are beginning to see what
they're capable of actually
accomplishing when they work together
without the inter party fights the
warfare inter-party they can actually do
a good deal of good
I'm told that president george w bush is
making calls on Cavanaugh's behalf and
it was very encouraging to see mcconnell
stand firm justice matters evidence
matters facts matter vague
unsubstantiated and uncorroborated
allegations of 30 plus year old
misconduct where all the supposed
witnesses either totally deny it or
can't confirm it is nowhere near grounds
to nullify someone's career or destroy
their good name amen and it's about time
all Republicans called this out what
they've done to Brett Kavanaugh for what
it is it's a total disgrace but the
Democrats of course conveniently looked
the other way when their heroes are
accused of rape abuse of interns and
even when they leave a woman to die in
five feet of water but Kavanagh with no
criminal record and no pattern of
abusive conduct must be destroyed at all
costs a lot of you may not know that
Texas Senate candidate Beto O'Rourke the
new darling of the left actually has a
criminal record including a DWI and a
burglary arrests but no big deal oh come
on
at least he condemned what happened to
Ted Cruz last night that
was nice negotiating with terrorists we
hear that it's always a bad idea almost
always by doing so what do you get you
get more terrorism it is good that the
GOP has not given in to this rabid mob
mentality because to do so would have
only emboldened the worst instincts of
the left senator Grassley's decision to
schedule the Cavanaugh committee vote
this Friday in the morning is another
positive development tonight if the GOP
continues to fight for fairness and
justice in the way that Trump has on
issue after issue we may not only see a
Justice Kavanagh we may just hold the
majority come November and that's the
angle